so
yes
thank you our next speaker is uh liam
solis from kth role institute in
stockholm
cool thank you very much
for everyone for coming and uh thanks to
the organizers for organizing such a
great workshop there's been some really
fantastic talks so far
really looking forward to the rest of
the week
so um
yeah today i would like to tell you a
little bit about some recent work with
eliana duarta currently at
representative
that actually evolved out of a project
where we were interested in
understanding the algebraic geometric
structure of uh interventional uh
graphical models and interventional dag
models to be specific
and to answer those those particular
more theoretical questions it turned out
to be helpful to pass to a more refined
representation of the dag model
uh something known as its stage tree
representation
and um
when exploring things from that
perspective we
started to wonder what what how can
these models which turn out to be much
more
diverse in a sense than our classic dag
models be used uh to give us uh more
refined uh but tractable
types of interventional models where we
can still prove the theorems that we
like but gain some diversity in what
we're modeling
so
those are those are the things that i
want to tell you a little bit about
today and i'll try and
tell you what we've observed so far and
leave you with some directions for where
i see the work generalizing
um so what's what's really the problem
that we're interested in here well
uh at the basis of the probabilistic
theory of causality right now the
starting point is is conditional
independence relations uh that we
observe in our observational
distribution and then we associate we
represent we represent those with a dag
model right
um but one immediate limitation to this
approach is that
um
that working with only these ci
relations limits our ability to capture
context-specific causal information
so such statements such as what are
called asymmetric ci relations or csi
relations where
uh in addition to our regular old
conditioning set we have some some
realization of the fourth set of
variables
so the first question we would want to
ask ourselves is uh how do we go about
representing these more granular sets of
relations and the context
context-specific causal information they
encode
um and this is not at all a new question
right so i mean this is something that's
been investigated from a variety of
perspectives over the last 30 years or
so maybe even longer
um but uh in particular the the family
that we wanted to work with these
these stage tree models uh in some sense
they're very simple to define and uh
represent a high level of diverse
context specific information
uh so we sort of wanted to explore what
we could do from that that side of
things
so our starting point is these stage
tree models um also called chain event
graphs that were introduced by smith and
anderson in 2008
and
as i said they're very they're very
straightforward to define a stage tree
model is really just a colored
probability tree over some subs over
some set of variables x1 through xn
uh where we start with some root node
and then the remaining nodes in the tree
correspond to realizations of subsets of
the variables
and
we add some colors to this tree for
example here these these two nodes are
blue
and these these colors represent that
the transition probabilities from these
current these two different states
are to their next state are actually
equal okay so in particular the
probability of going from x3
given that x1 x2 is 1 1
is the same as going to x3 event x1 x2
is zero one
is the blue stage
and uh to simplify things when we're
representing these models uh to avoid
too many colors
if we make a node white that just means
that it's a color of its own it has its
own set of transition probabilities
so
what is our model that we're actually
interested in studying here well each of
these different stages each of these
different colors
now needs some some transition
probability parameters here
and these can be some numbers between
zero and one that sum to one so we map
from all such set of possibilities into
the probability simplex by
multiplying along the root to leaf paths
in this tree
so this cuts out a subset of
distributions
that is our stage tree model mt
and we're interested in studying uh the
structure of these models right
so as i said these these stage tree
models while including families of dags
can do much more diverse
context-specific things
so for instance
if we don't color the tree in this nice
symmetric way that i'm coloring it here
but we do something like this instead
we're now encoding things like the trend
the probability of 3 given x 1 x 2 0 1
is the same as the probability of 2
given x 1 is 1.
we can also do things like in different
contexts
switch switch the
the partial order imposed on our
variables right so unlike a dag model
there's no need to restrict to a certain
partial order so in the context x1 is
one maybe the next variable is two but
when x1 is zero the next variable is
three
but
we can go even further so for example
doing things like truncating the trees
we can encode
missing data or unobserved outcomes in
certain contexts but also we can also
very easily represent a hard
intervention so for example if you want
to do x2 is equal to one we just
truncate the tree there okay
so
um more recently these have also been
extended to models that allow for
stochastic soft interventions
so here the idea is now that we want to
pick maybe in some certain contexts a
subset of these transition probabilities
that we allow to vary between our
experiments
and the other ones should remain in
variance right
so just similar to the the dag model
setting
so for instance if we wanted to do two
different experiments then we would take
two copies of our tree here
and we would replace these root nodes
with our different intervention targets
which can now be context specific
so for instance maybe in the first
experiment we intervene at we target
three in the context x2 is zero
so that would correspond to targeting
these transition probabilities
and all that it means is that since we
don't do that target since since we're
targeting that in this experiment then
when we look up here we should allow for
different parameters in the same stage
up here
similarly in this experiment we maybe we
target two and the context x one is zero
so now these transition probability
parameters should be allowed to vary
from these ones
um but abiding by the rule of
invariances we should consider all other
causal mechanisms in their different
contexts
invariant between the two trees so for
example since we don't target
x2 in the context x1 is one then these
parameters should be identical to these
so then we can color the tree to to
capture this in variance right
so
now we start to
see the issue right so we have these
very simple to define models that are
highly expressive but i only have three
binary variables and two experiments and
it takes up the entire
wall right and it's it's quite difficult
to look at this massive picture
and read off immediately causal
information in the way that we like to
do with causal bayesian networks
so
this sort of brings us to the downside
of working with these these models right
so while they
have a high level of expressive
capability this comes at a cost
in particular uh they lack easy human
interpretability
like this this stage tree that i drew
that we started with here
actually just encodes the ci relation
one is an independent of three given two
so it's much easier just to work with
the the causal path right
um
at the same time this added level of
expressiveness means that it's more
difficult to prove the theorems that we
get so much mileage out of with dag
models so for instance
it's difficult to come up with global
markov properties or structural
characterizations of model equivalents
things that drive our learning
algorithms right
so
uh this is in some sense a major
downside because
global market properties are nice right
they allow us to do things like
read more complex csi relations from the
representation right now it's it's
really only easy to see
the relations implied directly by the
coloring anything more complicated than
that you have to do some
some mental yoga
um
but going beyond that the global markov
properties often are our main tool for
proving characterizations of model
equivalence or interventional model
equivalents and in turn these these
drive many of our structural learning
algorithms like ges or the pc algorithm
or things like this
so where are we at well we've defined a
very general family of models and in the
universe of all sort of statistical
models we can maybe think of stage trees
as being a super cluster of models
and the dags as being a galaxy within
right
um and the question that we really want
to know is what are the things that are
bounded to dags by gravity what are the
models
where we can prove the theorems that we
like that generalize what we know about
dags and start to make use out of them
to to do these sorts of things right
so
so this is the question we want to know
for which stage trees can we prove the
theorems that we like to use
where can we get these nice global
markov properties that lead to
structural characterizations of
interventional model equivalents
so um as i said i kind of want to view
this talk and its results as a starting
point for this this exploration
and the the claim is is that
at least one family that we can identify
exists within this this local group
around dags um
and this is a set of models that we're
currently calling these cs trees
so um to do this to define this family
we have to restrict
this set of stage three models and
essentially start by doing away with
some of the fun context specific things
you were looking at first but hopefully
we'll see natural roads as we analyze
them for for bringing some of this
complexity back into the picture
so the first thing that we need to do is
impose that actually we're not allowed
to change the partial order or change
the total order variables within
different contexts so right now
two comes after four and when one is
zero and two comes our three comes after
two and the context
uh x1 is one
but we're not going to allow that we
need to abide by some total order of the
variables for now so we have to say
maybe one two three four one two three
four right
we're also not going to allow right now
for truncation right so we need to
assume that all of our root to leaf
paths have length n
so there's no sort of unobserved
outcomes for now
um
and these two properties combined
already help us sort of simplify this
picture a bit
uh if we make these two assumptions then
it's very easy to keep track of what the
nodes in this tree actually are
so we have always our root node but then
given this this total order the nodes at
level at distance k from the root node
in the tree
correspond to the the realizations of
the first k variables in our total order
right
and if we just remember that up at zero
and down is one well then we can just
draw this picture instead which is a bit
easier to work with
so um
now these two properties
are maybe not the most critical at first
uh but then
the real sort of critical properties
that we're going to work with
deal with how we go about coloring this
tree how we put things into these
different stages
um and the first condition on that is
that
we're only going to allow nodes that
correspond to realizations of the same
length so at the same distance in the
tree or in the same level of the tree to
be the same color so right now these two
yellow nodes this is a realization of
the first two variables and this is a
realization of the first three variables
so we're going to exclude that we're
going to say
we need something like this instead
okay
and then perhaps the most critical
property
is that uh for every stage
so now a stage is something that exists
in in level k so it's a realization of
the first k variables
we're going to want that they they all
contain some common sub context say xc
that we call this stage defining context
of the tree
and the stage itself then has to be
defined by allowing all of the other
all of the other variables
that correspond to that level to vary
through their different possibilities
okay
so right now this tree satisfies this
condition so this one is genuinely a cs
tree
but for example this orange stage
corresponds to all of the realization
all of the realizations of x1 x2 x3
where we have x1 is 1 and x2 is or x3 is
0. but if say we wanted to include this
node as well well then the only common
subcontext would be x1 is 1 so we'd have
to include this note as well right so we
get some sort of swallowing property
so why would i do all of this work
well i want something that is similar to
dax right
and this actually allows our stages
to this actually allows our model to not
just be defined by this
this multiplication along these
root-to-leap paths but now our stages
are actually associated to very specific
types of csi relations right
there are things that look like this and
now we can think of our model as being
generated by these relations
as opposed to just this this
multiplication right so now we have in
some sense say
a local markov property or something
like this
so
given that we can now sort of
think of our model as being defined by
these relations
then we can do what we do with tags
right we start with the relations that
generate the the model and we ask what
are all the csi relations that that
these imply
so we need to look at the associated
context-specific conditional
independence model so
those csi relations that are implied
implied by
some context-specific conditional
independence axioms
so
these are
just an extension of the classic
conditional independence axioms like
symmetry and decomposition and weak
union
and for each of these we just are going
to tack on this context and it just
carries through to the other side of the
statement
but then we also need some way of moving
between these different
contexts so the natural way to do that
is to think about something such as
specialization and absorption right
so in the specialization case well we
have we carry condition on this set here
and we have this context here but if we
take some subset of the variables here
and specialize them to a certain
realization we've just extended this
context right
going the other way
if we take some subset of our context
so here
and we can change to any other
realization those variables those
variables outcome and still get the same
looking csi relation well then we can
absorb that piece over here and shrink
this context right
so
you applying all these rules iteratively
we can generate the entire
context-specific conditional
independence model
and then ask sort of what are the key
generators in this and can we find some
some underlying generators here based on
these choices of context that capture
everything that we want but maybe expose
more of the global structure of these
csi relations so
what do we use for that well here we
look at what we call these minimal
contexts so these are just contexts in
which there exists some
csi relation
that is not implied by specialization of
anything else so it's sort of at the
bottom of these relations right
so we collect all of these minimal
contexts into a set c t
and then we can start using these to try
and represent a model instead
so how do we do that
well we now have our minimal contacts
that come from the tree and we have this
total order here so what we can do is
just look at all of the
csi relations with that given minimal
context
and take a minimal imap with respect to
this order here okay so for instance in
this tree one can find that the minimal
contacts are actually x one is zero x
two is zero x three is zero
and then we just take a minimal a
minimal imap of the csi relations
with each of those contexts and it gives
us these three graphs
now
the idea is that
is that what we would want to see is
that
in this representation where we can see
more
well for this very small example we just
see pairwise relations but for
large examples we would want to see that
this is telling us
a larger set of csi relations right so
what we want is that
any distribution that is in some sense
markov to this sequence here
is actually in this model here and vice
versa
so
what do we say we
define being mark after the sequence of
graphs as just saying that
the distribution will entail a csi
relation
if and only if uh
in the given context
whenever there's an a whenever a and b
are deseparated given s in the context
graph and this has to be true for all of
these context graphs
contextcraft sorry
so um
if we do this then
it turns out that we would give what we
want right
a distribution will be in this this
model mt if and only if it's marked up
to the sequence of context graphs
so
this in some sense is our global markov
property it's not complete we can't read
off every
csi relation
encoded by
encoded by the model from these context
graphs but we can certainly read off
more of them
so
um and in fact we can read off enough of
them that we can actually get structural
characterization similar to the verma
pearl type characterization of of model
of diag model equivalents so in
particular
we see that two stage tree models are
actually equal our csg models are
actually equal
if and only if they have the same set of
minimal contacts and if
if we fix one of these minimal contexts
then their two
context graphs have to be markov
equivalent right
so we can reduce it to looking at
skeletons and b structures
so for instance here we could we can
actually generate a cs tree
that has this as its sequence of context
graphs and we see in the first two
contexts it's just identical
and then the last one we've reversed
scenario but we haven't introduced any
uh b structures so these two models
actually represent
these two cs trees actually represent
the same model
now
this is just the observational story
but what we're really interested in here
is what can we say in the case of soft
stochastic interventions
so we want to turn back to these these
larger interventional trees that we were
looking at before and see if we can do
the same sort of thing
so now here remember our
our set of interventions is some
collection of subsets of stages in t
so for instance in this tree we're we're
intervening at two in the context x one
is zero
and uh three in the context that
that x one is zero so that's these two
stages here
and we encode that by having them be
different colors between these two trees
right
so our interventional model just says
that for each of our
intervention
targets we have a different distribution
they're all
markov to this cs tree
and
if we don't intervene in two different
experiments
if we don't intervene at a certain node
then the associated transition
probabilities are invariant
okay
so
um
now what would we do
well what we would what we'd hope we
could do is just do what we would do in
the case of dags right we would just
want to take our context graphs
augment them based on the interventional
experiments add some nodes and arrows
and hopefully get out the same sort of
result right
so in this case
we also will just add in this for
bookkeeping purposes this uh
minimal imap of the entire tree
um but how do we go about doing this
augmentation process well for
for each of our
non-observational experiments we're
going to add in a node so here we have
one it's this i2
so we add in the node wi-2 here and
we're going to draw an arrow
in these context graphs from our
interventional node to the targeted node
so long as the node is targeted within
this context right
so for instance three is targeted in the
context x1 is zero and 2 is targeted in
the context x1 is 0
and nothing is targeted in the context
that x1 is 1.
so we should add
these two arrows in that context
and that implies some arrows in the in
the empty context
but there's no content no arrows added
in the case when x1 is one
okay
so
now one would hope that
this is sufficient right that we could
take for example an extension of the the
i markov property of yang at all from
2008
and say that a sequence of distributions
is in a sense markov to
this
this set of data this sequence of dags
if and only if it's in the
interventional model for this tree here
um
but uh so what that would amount to
saying is that we want each of these to
satisfy this markov property with
respect to
the entire sequence of context graphs
that's all this first condition is
saying
and then we would want to satisfy a
second condition related to invariances
um which just says that
if i
if i have some with if i fix a minimal
context
and i have two disjoint sets of nodes a
and s
and the set a is d separated from the
interventional node given s and the
other nodes
then i should see
invariance in the distribution of a
given s in that context right
so
so one would hope that this works um
but we have to be careful the thing is
is here we sort of picked our
interventions very nicely but we could
pick them in a stranger way right we
just pick stages for these interventions
and one option here would be for example
to also have intervened at this green
stage right so if we intervened here we
would allow these transition
probabilities to be perturbed in the
context x1 is one
which would mean that we should add in
an arrow from
wi-2 to 3 in that graph
but
if we then consider that sort of by
markov property with respect to this
sequence here
then we would actually be missing an
invariance that's a defining property of
our of our model here right we wouldn't
be able to recover this in variance of
these two blue nodes because it's
somehow obscured by this arrow
so
the quick fix for this is to
to refine our intervention targets so
one the way to go about doing that to
make sure everything works out is to
say that a set of intervention targets
is complete if whenever there's
some node in some stage in the target
then it needs to satisfy two conditions
first
we need that there is some minimal
context uh that that is a subcontext of
that node
meaning that the target will actually be
recorded in one of these graphs
and the second one that helps us avoid
this issue that we're seeing here is
that
if there's some other node with that
same sub-context then it will also be
targeted so that would prevent us from
having this sort of blue-green paradigm
happening
so in that case we can get out the
theorems that we want right we can see
that this context-specific imark off
property is actually our global markov
property
for these interventional cs trees
and we can derive uh a structural
characterization of model equivalence
again
in particular
uh if we draw these two diagrams for
each of our cs trees we should see the
same
you should see the same minimal context
with the same skeletons and b structures
now
um so this is what we've been able to
observe so far but after having walked
through this story
it's sort of clear that there's lots of
room for for generalization and there's
been lots of nice talks so far that
focus on
uh their work is sort of a starting
point for things to do and
and i really like that idea because it's
it hopefully helps us have some broader
discussions while we're here this week
so i just wanted to end with uh some a
few obvious ways that
i see us being able to generalize these
things
so everything that we've done so far has
hinged on this set of
of minimal context the set ct
and uh even this example that we just
looked at of intervening at this green
node and not this blue node
suggests that the right way to go about
generalizing the story is to extend this
set right
so
one way to do that in the interventional
case is to introduce some notion of
minimal and variance contexts so we add
some context to it where we actually can
record this additional polynomial
constraint to this and variance of the
blue stage when x1 is 1 and x3 is 1.
or x2 is 1 whatever it was
in a similar fashion we can start trying
to ask if we can bring in some of these
nice
context-specific properties that we set
aside when we were first defining these
models
in particular
if we don't want to impose a total order
of the variables but allow the order to
vary in context-specific settings we
should just take some minimal context
that
in which they abide by some some total
order
and same thing with missing data we can
we can do a similar restriction there
and just extend this family of graphs to
to hopefully generalize this family and
find more models where we can prove the
theorems that we like to prove
um if we don't want to explore those
questions we can already start trying to
make use of these results here
so so far we've implemented some very
basic uh causal discovery algorithms
but there's more work to be done so now
that we have structural
characterizations of model equivalence
we can ask about
can we give
things like a consistent generalization
of ges to this family
or in the case of the stochastic soft
interventions
where gies fails to be consistent we can
ask about other algorithms such as the
interventional greedy sp algorithm if we
can give a consistent generalization
thereof
so um i'll stop there and thank you very
much for listening
thank you very much for the nice talk we
have a half hour break now and then
after that uh uh chris harsher will give
the third talk of this session and then
we'll have the panel with all the
questions then
coffee is outside see you again in half
an hour thank you